depuis le 1er août 2023 la Chine dispose
d'un nouveau cadre pour ses exportations
de gallium et de germanium des matériaux
essentiels pour nos systèmes de défense
pour me laisser mi-conducteur de nos
véhicules électriques pour nos
infrastructures 5G nos éclairages LED
des matériaux dont 80% de nos besoins
viennent de Chine désormais les
autorités chinoises peuvent restreindre
nos approvisionnements sur ces matières
premières critiques c'est notre laisser
faire qui nous a conduit à cette
situation et il était temps que l'Europe
se dote d'un cadre pour les
approvisionnements sûrs et durables en
matière première critique pour ne plus
créer de dépendance pour privilégier des
partenariats avec des pays qui partagent
nos valeurs et nos principes pour
garantir que la transition technologique
et environnementale participent aussi au
juste développement ainsi avec ce
travail nous répondons à un double défi
le risque la réduction des risques pour
les Européens et la garantie de notre
autonomie stratégique sans tourner le
dos à nos partenaires pour ne pas le
faire notre développement sur aussi leur
développement c'est la vision que nous
avons défendu avec Nicolas Bert c'est
nous devons y être fiers et nous devons
être tous aux résultats je vous remercie
pendant des années nous avons accru nos
dépendances laissez la maîtrise des
chaînes d'approvisionnement matériaux
critiques à nos rivaux systémiques et
nous en payons le prix il était temps de
réagir et de privilégier des
approvisionnements avec des partenaires
avec qui nous partageons des principes
et des valeurs à ce titre cet accord
avec les États-Unis trouve sa place mais
la politique américaine n'est pas
toujours l'ami de l'Europe remise en
cause du cadre de l'OMC politique
protectionniste de l'IRA sanctions
extra-territoriales il est donc légitime
et sain de nous interroger sur les
conséquences de cet accord où se
trouvent l'étude d'impact comment
assurer que les effets de notre
Règlement sur les matières premières
critiques ne soient pas remise en cause
par cet accord spécifique nous devons
certes réduire les risques sans
découpler nos relations avec nos alliés
mais nous devons le faire avec notre cap
celui de notre autonomie stratégique qui
doit rester le pilier de notre politique
industrielle et commerciale